[Applauso]
andata e ritorno
se ci pensate quando acquistiamo un
viaggio online la prima cosa da fare
prima ancora di digitare la destinazione
è decidere se vogliamo un volo di sola
andata o di andata e ritorno nel nostro
immaginario il viaggio di sola andata e
quello che ha il sapore dell'avventura e
quello che molti di noi vorrebbero fare
ma che non osano fare oppure è quella
via d'uscita che vorremmo avere quando
ne abbiamo le scatole piene della serie
basta non ne posso più parto vado e vado
invece il viaggio di andata e ritorno è
quello che noi conosciamo al viaggio
diciamo e la vacanza per cui prendo
parto vado visito faccio le foto ma
sempre tenendo in mente la data di
ritorno e questo funziona anche se noi
usiamo il viaggio come metafora della
vita partenza la nascita arrivo la morte
in mezzo sta appunto il viaggio e
proviamo un attimo così per assurdo
immaginare di fare del nostro viaggio un
viaggio di sola andata
un viaggio di quelli vado vado vado come
cambierebbe la nostra esistenza con il
mitico elisir di lunga vita
insomma potremmo fare un mutuo che dura
a 350 anni potremmo fare il giro del
mondo
non so quattro volte io lo farei in
vespa potremmo imparare otto lingue
insomma avremo un sacco di tempo potremo
fare un sacco di cose ne avanzeremo
ancora non avremo paura delle malattie
perché tanto insomma questa prospettiva
questa questa idea di avere di fronte
una vita con una data di scadenza è
sicuramente come dire si influenza
perché avete mai veramente riflettuto su
quanto la morte
questa appunto questa data condiziona cc
condiziona pesantemente la morte noi
siamo abituati a considerarla come
qualcosa che sta al di fuori della
nostra vita ma in realtà ne è parte
integrante proprio perché tutta
l'architettura della nostra esistenza si
basa proprio su questa data che per
fortuna non ci è dato sapere ma è una
certezza è l'unico appuntamento
imprescindibile che tutti noi abbiamo è
uguale per tutti però è un argomento
tabù è un argomento di cui solitamente
non siamo a parlare un argomento che
evitiamo e questo perché perché
innanzitutto non sappiamo per certo cosa
e semplici aspetta qualcosa nell'altra
parte e poi anche perché la morte è
assoluta
non puoi fare ricorso è che puoi
metterti a discutere con quella voglio
dire quando è fatta è fatta per certo
poi sappiamo anche che fa male si fa
paura e fa male mentre noi siamo
programmati per evitare il dolore
secondo alcune teorie di psicologia
sociale
come l'unico animale ad essere coscienti
di dover morire però come tutti gli
animali ha paura della morte di
conseguenza l'unica cosa che può fare
per sopportare questa questa condizione
non restare paralizzato dal
dall'angoscia e quella di relegare la
consapevolezza della finitudine nel suo
inconscio e questo ci crea un senso di a
volte di paura di smarrimento siamo
siamo un po persi in questa nostra
condizione e e ci fa una paura una paura
cane perché perdere una persona amata
perché c'è anche questo da dire che la
morte c'è più che la nostra ci fa paura
alla morte di una persona amata dei
nostri familiari questo cosa significa
significa non averli più voglio dire
fisicamente non poterli abbracciare non
potergli parlare non sentire più le loro
carezze e questo crea un senso di
smarrimento la perdita di vuoto e questo
vuoto
e proprio questo vuoto che crea quel
dolore che un dolore che ti toglie
l'energia volte veramente per cui fai
fatica puoi andare avanti giorno dopo
giorno senza la persona amata
ma forse è opportuno anche fare una
distinzione tra la morte è lutto la
morte loot sono due parole che vanno
come dire sono correlate tra di loro ma
che a ben guardare sono distinte per che
hanno un soggetto diverso
poniamo che sono io a morire ben tal
caso non parliamo neanche di lutto nel
senso se sono io
finisce tutto lì sensi c'è un'altra
persona a morire
lei muore io sono in lutto quindi sono
due concetti lutto la morte che si
accompagnano ma che sono diversi tra
loro
perché veramente la morte di per sé non
ha niente di spaventoso fa parte del
naturale ciclo della vita la morte nei
tarocchi per esempio è rappresentata
dalla carta numero 13 che nonostante
questo aspetto così un po spaventoso non
ha veramente nulla di negativo anzi ha
proprio una connotazione positiva e ci
indica come a volte sia proprio
necessario un cambiamento e come ogni
cambiamento ci obbliga a lasciar andare
cosa qui siamo molto legati ma che non
ci servono più per la nostra crescita
personale
quindi si indica come ad ogni fine
corrisponde un nuovo inizio e vedete
insomma di per sé proprio la morte è
l'evento più naturale che ci sia
se vogliamo invece adottare una
prospettiva completamente diversa
potremmo anche dire che noi moriamo di
un giorno ogni giorno
eppure questo non ci non ci spaventa
seneca diceva duemila anni fa nelle
lettere a lucilio può indicarmi qualcuno
che dia un giusto valore al suo tempo e
alla sua giornata che capisca di morire
ogni giorno
ecco il nostro errore vediamo la morte
davanti a noi invece gran parte di essa
è già le nostre spalle
appartiene alla morte la vita passata in
questa prospettiva noi ogni giorno ci
viene sottratta una piccola parte della
vita
the man mano che noi cresciamo la vita
decresce è proprio questo il giochino
noi cresciamo lei decresce io per
esempio a 50 anni ho già passato
l'infanzia la gioventù sono già nell'età
matura invece il lutto e lutto quello
quelle bastardo quello che ci fa
veramente male nel lutto e quello che
che veramente ci si morde alle caviglie
e che ci fa sentire come come se ci
mancasse un pezzo e questo perché perché
i protagonisti siamo noi siamo noi che
siamo i diretti interessati quelli che
sono coinvolti in prima persona e quindi
che devono far fronte a questa realtà
nel suo nella sua teoria ormai famosa la
psichiatra svizzera elizabeth kubler ros
lei identifica cinque fasi nella
elaborazione del lutto la coppia rosa
dedicato alla vita e gli studi e malati
terminali e lei ha elaborato appunto
queste cinque fasi come tappe
obbligatorie per una sana e serena
elaborazione del lutto la negazione o
rifiuto la rabbia la contrattazione o il
patteggiamento la depressione infine
l'accettazione non è certo la sede per
analizzare questi punti 1 a 1 ma era
solo per dire appunto che il lutto è un
percorso e queste fasi vanno
attraversati tutte e richiede anche un
grosso lavoro di scavo alla propria
interiorità e è un lavoro duro che si è
passato lo sa ma è anche un tipo di
analisi che ci dice tanto sulle nostre
risorse interiori la nostra forza le
nostre appunto le nostre risorse
anche perché il lutto di dare ti
colpisce quando meno te lo aspetti
e anche nel caso di malattie protratte
nel tempo di persone anziane e come se
non fossimo mai pronti ad affrontare la
morte di conseguenza al lotto è un po
come non so se vi ricordate quando
eravamo bambini si giocava palla
avvelenata palla avvelenata si correva
come dei dannati c'era un battitore che
cercava di colpirti con la palla se ti
colpiva dovevi fare la penitenza e la
pazienza consisteva né stare in
equilibrio magari su un piede solo e
contare fino mettiamo a 10 ecco il lutto
come se è un gioco del destino che ti
tira addosso questa palla avvelenata e
ti obbliga a fare la penitenza e tu devi
stare fermo per un po di tempo su un
piede solo senza nessun appiglio a
cercare di nuovo il tuo equilibrio
l'equilibrio interiore
perché vedete secondo me proprio la
genesi del senso di smarrimento da cui
poi il dolore è proprio il fatto che non
abbiamo un appiglio nella nostra vita
noi siamo abituati a pensare di stare
sui nostri piedi di appoggiare il nostro
peso sui nostri piedi ma in realtà noi
siamo molto spesso siamo appoggiati alle
vite dei nostri cari
riempiamo la nostra vita con la vita la
vita dei nostri affetti ci facciamo
carico delle loro gioie del loro dolore
e questo per carità è bellissimo ma
quando poi questo appoggio e ci viene a
mancare e beh siamo fregati coeli poi
cade per terra
nell'elaborazione del lutto il pianto è
sacrosanto lo dice anche la kubler ros e
fa parte di una sana elaborazione però
dice anche che ognuno ha i suoi tempi e
dice anche che non c'è una correlazione
tra la quantità di lacrime e l'amore che
sia per il trapassato e quindi io voglio
farvi una domanda che è volutamente
provocatoria se noi ci facciamo
veramente un esame di coscienza
possiamo dire se a distanza di tempo
piangiamo ancora disperatamente senza
reagire per la persona che trapassata
oppure piangiamo perché noi non abbiamo
più un appiglio nella nostra vita
perché vedete perdere una persona cara
una persona importante ti obbliga a
rimetterti
al centro della tua vita e questa è una
consapevolezza e fa molta paura perchè
significa sostanzialmente prendersi le
proprie responsabilità significa
significa guardarsi dentro e significa
crescere
ecco che a mio modo di vedere anche una
perdita tragica anche un lutto tragico
comunque è una grande opportunità di
crescita e avrete notato che non uso mai
il termine non dico mai perdere una
persona cara ma sempre smarrire perché
straperdere smarrire c'è una differenza
sono due sinonimi però hanno un
significato rimandano un significato
subliminale diverso perché in perdere
c'è questo senso della sconfitta questo
senso della non ci si può più fare
niente come dire invece smarrire ha in
sé il senso della temporaneità e il
senso del va bene se non lo trovo ma
prima o poi salterà fuori c'è una
speranza cioè quanto meno una positività
a cui io non voglio rinunciare e vi dico
tutto questo col sorriso e con la
consapevolezza di chi ci è passata
perché io quella che vi ho raccontato è
la mia storia la mia personale
elaborazione del lutto
cinque anni fa ho smarrito mia figlia
gaia
l'hanno trovata morta su una spiaggia in
brasile il giorno di natale è stata
uccisa non si sa da chi perché ma io
sono fermamente convinta di aver
smarrito non di averla persa al suo
assassino non penso semplicemente molto
semplicemente ecco la gaia molto
semplicemente io non penso a chi le ha
fatto del male l'ho perdonato perché
voglio trattenere nel mio cuore solo lei
e la sua bellezza e mi piace pensare che
lei sia qui con noi in questo momento in
questo teatro
per cui bisogna anche che stia attenta a
quello che dico se no uno zoo e io
vorrei farvi questo invito a chi magari
si è imbattuto in questa esperienza io
vorrei dire accettate lutto come una
grazia e non come una disgrazia e
intendo non solo il lutto per morte il
lutto anche inteso come perdita del
lavoro come come trasferimento come
qualunque evento della vita che ci
obbliga lasciar andare le nostre
certezze per trovarla sicurezza dentro
di noi non fuori dentro e poi io vorrei
anche dirvi amate le ha fatte per quello
che sono
a prescindere dal lutto amate i vostri
figli i vostri partner i vicini di casa
la suocera il capufficio amateli per
quello che sono e non per quello che voi
vorreste anche loro fossero perché nei
loro difetti nei loro limiti sta la
bellezza è quello è l'amore quello è
l'amore con la a maiuscola
io gaia l'ho apprezzata pienamente solo
quando è morta lo so è bruttissimo da
dirsi per una madre è una cosa
bruttissima però lo dico con l'umiltà
della persona che sono diventata grazie
a lei io prima non vedevo la donna
meravigliosa che lei era perché ero
accecata dalle mie dalle mie dai miei
limiti le mie paure le mie proiezione le
aspettative e quindi non vedevo tutto il
bello che c'era
ho dovuto perdere il suo corpo
ho dovuto smarrire il suo corpo per
amare integralmente il suo spirito e non
fate il mio stesso errore per favore
grazie buon viaggio